oh what a burger can I get your ah 30
sausage biscuits there you ash Browns Oh
an egg an egg and cheese on those please
hold on now we're trying a little
napkins it's all about the Brotherhood
after pledging lambda man is ready for
anything it's a rite of passage we go
iron the [ __ ] you are in the good hands
of generations of tradition
grigory rod and honorable brothers don't
make it through hell man that'll be us
I'm here you know that the breads gonna
be in the family now I'm gonna eat bags
for life this right here you come from
kings and queens not slaves
you you you kinks hello yes sir
I'll be there in 10 minutes yes sir how
bad you want it boys I want to be a
sound let me tell you something about
gaining that return
find out what just any people will
quietly submit to and you found out the
exact measure of injustice and wrong I
think it's tough enough
suevel hell night if we ever get free
from the oppressions wrongs heaped upon
us we must pay for the removal your
engine aren't you you really should get
it looked at I'm just trying to keep my
okay why only chosen for you make it to
the other side why no matter you don't
want to keep your love rose wait I don't
think you understand humiliation builds
humility and one more night is not gonna
kill you this I know we need to change
and even now because the lives of our
students and the harmony with this
fraternity in this state you are merely
facing what other men have met
you're up against rain really squarely
face to face if you change stations
playing for you taking brace and it's
vain to try and add do the best that you
can do you make bail you may conquer see
you dude
see you dude
welcome to hell life else there were six
singularities
forged into in fish